[Music]
welcome to Rotten Tomatoes killer kill
streets so poor soils at the Rotten
Tomatoes office have tallied the victims
of cinema's most iconic horror choice
ping this video will mash up some of
them notably Pierce and crunch the
numbers to find out which killers have
spilt the most human tomato juice on
stream who do you think's been killing
it
[Music]
pinhead Hellraiser series over the
course of 94 suited everyone's favorite
glorified drops in cushion killed an
estimated 35 people now that might not
seem like a lot because it's not it
takes him at the bottom of our list
however his notable killed season
killing it on the dance floor literally
in Hellraiser 3 pinhead seems to take
out an entire night club for people and
all because they didn't have any easy
tragic
[Music]
Tom [__] with the Chuck Chucky
child's play series
forever changing the definition of an
adult play duck Chucky's playtime murder
spree expanded six films with cuteness
on his side you can wipe out an entire
puppy convention
unfortunately this kill streak manages
to just inch above pinheads at 38
[__] kidney bother his notable kill
comes with a great contemporary Russia
hey internet pranksters it definitely
can happen see hope you got good lawyers
welcome to my Freddy but my there on Elm
Street series
unfortunately we need to keep this one
short due to they feel too little fun
copyright but you dreaming if you think
we're gonna leave the prints of
nightmares off the list you might be
surprised to see him so early on here
with eight gnomes including Randall
Freddie has surprisingly only sent 39
people to rest in pieces
the freddie is an artiste crafting
clever and refined nightmares as sharp
as his clock tip gloves just check out
his mode McGill's after told Annie's and
chosen because of copyright
look at that what is that Sara fought
magnificent Ghostface stream series
[Music]
there's nothing worse than a know-it-all
movie buff killer right except 9/11 over
the course of four films and a two
season television series nine dos-based
killers have donned eiectric much
inspired masks but perhaps most
impressive than the 57 coins they put
away is the dead wolf signet where he
kills them spoiling us with over the
years
Chickie's oh you got to bury no more the
Soarin over California guy and that guy
from the OSI Sarah Michelle thaller
Annie's boobs Adam Sandler's father
figure every Adam Sandler movie ever
dead Ernie have Schreiber Jenny oh
what's she up to McCarthy and Jamie
Kennedy I got hi another method problem
I want to play a game jigsaw saw series
jigsaw or John Kramer it's a special
place in the pantheon of killers for
never having physically killed any of
this victims house it's like Will Smith
not cussing in his raps
a little lame but stay effective in a
seven filled run he and his successors
have built nearly 70 games testing their
victims will to live
this hands-free killing lifestyle as um
jigsaw sixty points on the street and
the games are over
sure there now we don't have a notable
kill as much as we do with notable
appearance saw the final chapter is the
red chester bennington final future
field appearance and all we have to say
sir is bravo Bravo
we're down to the final two Michael
Myers Halloween series although your
parents may have described us pure evil
anyone was he tired The Smiths gross
sanitarium escapee he is that he
embodies it in the literal sense Michael
has spread his legend across nine films
and most terrifyingly with no clear
motivation he just kills Michaels body
camp is at an insane 107 kills so wait
silent no motivation one of the best at
what he does what inspiration seminar
did I miss and we have to give his
notebook kill to his final confrontation
with Jamie Lee Curtis in Halloween
resurrection Michael finally gets what
he's been chasing for for TV films
killing his sister Lois Road plow in his
arms dangling off the side of a building
goodbye Lord
okay she's not dead beyond though all
right but just let the man have it for a
little while longer you know and at
number one Jason Friday the 13th series
letting the whole but he wasn't the
killer in the 1st and 5th movies aside
the hockey mask Donnie machete-wielding
Titan has still put up real numbers with
the most films on the list at 10
jason has diversified his hunting drugs
expanding from Crystal Lake to New York
Hades and even space that is how you
become a champ people I don't walk in
146 kills he has the highest kill streak
of any killer in the game his odd mode
will kill my ice have had some
otherworldly explanation to his success
in Freddy vs. Jason Jason terrorizes a
high school feel funny while literally
on fire while watch closely as he goes
for this poor man his choice for weapon
is liquid did you see that leader that
man suffers from spontaneous flirtation
or Jason killed him with hair we'd like
to go for the web
and there you have it folks
the killstreaks of cinema's most iconic
killers and although jason takes the
lead for now with sequels and reboots on
the rise we can expect the numbers to
change again soon see you at the next
count